Ngoài Mê Chín tháng 8, 1 yên chính trăm 4.5 gí giấu tháng lợi của cách mạng thẳng tắm,
đưa ra dân tộc Việt Nam thoát hỏi ác đô hộ gần một thế ki,
lập nên nước Việt Nam dân chủ cộng hoa.
8.5 sau, Ngoài Mê Chín tháng 8, 5.5 gả nước tương bình tổ chức lễ khánh thành
khởi câu 2,5 mươi công trình, dự án tại 8.5 gí điểm câu,
cho 1 khó khánh ngày 1,2 tháng chính.
Điểm câu chú tâm đặt tại chú tâm hội trở chỉ lắm cuốc gia đông anh, Thà Nội.
Các điểm câu lớn khác có cộng ngọt hội,
Hà Nội, xinh bài xa mình, bác đình, khu tài định cư đồng văn,
ninh bình, bình vệ uống bử vệ án, nhà máy định gió hại anh, quảng chiếc.
Á phía năm, thành phố Chí Vinh tổ chức tại chú tâm tại chíng quốc tế
sẽ gòn marina, đồng tháp hạnh thành câu dịch v組 hài,
ca mâu khởi công cơ tốt cả mâu, ca nước, đường đất mũi,
cao hòn khoi và cao hòn khòi.
Đến ngày 18 tháng 8, cả nước có hai chăm năm 2019,
trình tại 18 mi tư tình thành đủ điều kiện khởi công,
hành thành với tổng vũn đầu tư khoảng 1,2% trự tì đồng.
Trong đó có tám mấy chiến dự án hoàn thành,
mô chăm só mấy mô dự án khởi công,
trải giống như lĩnh vực, hà tần ra thông,
dân dụng, công nghiệp, ký thuật và nhà ở xa hội.
Nếu công chính tiêu biểu được đưa vào sự dụng như chung tâm
chính lám cuốc gia tại đông anh, câu dịch biểu 2,
mình vệ uống bử nếu án, đồng thời khởi công chung tâm nghiên cứu phát triển vệ theo,
câu tóc và càng biển lớn, tạo động lực phát triển cho xe đạn mối.